feuille man est-ce que c'est ton projet
de l'année
vous êtes dur oui et non la comédie
est-ce que c'est mieux que le drame non
dans le film mascarade tu te barres d'un
resto sans payer est-ce que c'était déjà
arrivé en vrai non est-ce que tu as déjà
vu des acteurs sans dormir au César oui
au mascarade est ton personnage a le mal
de mer est-ce que tu as le mal de mer
oui j'ai fait l'Antarctique une fois
j'étais pas fière tu conseillerais
docteur juif un pote non pas un pote que
j'aime bien en tout cas au Festival de
Cannes est-ce que le plus important
c'est les soirées
non
est-ce que le cinéma polytro ah oui sans
doute oui est-ce que tu as déjà regretté
d'avoir joué dans un film
non est-ce que tu as peur de prendre
l'avion
moins qu'avant ça va mieux je me soigne
dans mascarade on nous dit que c'est
impossible de se frapper soi-même est-ce
que tu as déjà essayé on peut mais c'est
très fort ouais
est-ce que le cinéma c'est mieux que le
théâtre